تواعد كفن مكارس الرئيس بالمحاسبه ردا على
زياره الرئيس الامريكي للحدود مع المكسيك
وذلك بعد يومين فقط من انتخابه رئيسا
لمجلس النواب الامريكي رئيس مجلس النواب
وصف زياره بايدن هذه بانها لاجل التقاط
صوره لاجل الدعايه انتخابيه كون بيدن ينوي
الترشح لرئاسه عام 2024 زياره تاتي بين
مكانه يضغط اي بيدن من اجل العفو عن
ملايين المهاجرين الذين عبروا الحدود الى
الولايات المتحده بشكل غير قانوني وفقا
لوصفي بكارثه الذي حذر من تداعيات هذه
الزياره قائلا ان الجمهوريين سيحاسبون
بيضا ووزير داخليته في مجلس النواب على
خلق اخطر ازمه حدوديه في التاريخ الامريكي
الجمهوريين الذين باتم يسيطرون على مجلس
النواب تعاهدوا اطلاق سلسله في سبل اداره
كورونا وقرار الانسحاب من افغانستان وقال
مكارثي من مقر مجلس النواب بعد اداءه
اليمين وتنصيبه خلفا للديمقراطيه
ناسيبيلوسي لقد حان الوقت لممارسه رقابه
على سياسه الرئيس الامريكي جوبادل